i gotta give this uh i gotta give this
shout out and talk about our good
friends over at the young turks because
we have this uh we have this video they
posted back on february 8th and it says
tim poole makes the dumbest january 6th
argument yet
oh this is just it feels so good to uh
there's so much to bring up in terms of
cultural politics and politics here that
this exemplifies i'm i'm grateful to be
a part of the story for those that
aren't familiar just to go back to our
previous segment in january i had made
the point that at the capitol many
people were let in the building by the
police that there were no barricades
they had been torn down and people
walked up cops were fanning them in
doors were being opened for them how
could you charge someone with trespass
if they were welcomed into a building
certainly that makes no sense right and
so taking that out of context some
twitter guy
takes a clip of it the young turks doing
no research
run the clip of it while smack talking
me saying i'm wrong and saying really
dumb poor legal arguments like if
there's broken glass on the ground it's
trespassing i think i think jen may have
said that where they're like i'm just
going to walk over this broken glass and
that means i'm allowed in and it's like
it doesn't mean you're not allowed in
broken glass is not a no trespassing
sign like imagine going to a mcdonald's
there's a broken window it's like i
guess i can't come into mcdonald's
someone broke the window no that's not
how it works
so they run this segment
and uh i am proud to say now that uh we
have been absolutely vindicated proven
right
judge issues the first outright
acquittal of a defendant charged over
the january 6 right we did just mention
this in a previous segment but here's
the best part
i tweeted
how it started how it's going with that
clip from the young turks with the new
article that comes out showing this
guy's been acquitted and i said hey anna
i was right
and their response is anna responded on
twitter as if
the news didn't come out she just
repeated the exact same false premise
on my argument while ignoring the fact
that even her false premise
so so i said the writers are gonna go to
jail the violent people go to jail she's
claiming that i'm saying the writers
themselves will be acquitted because
there's no signs which is a gross
exaggeration of my point but
a guy was acquitted this is what they do
so i think it's a really great um
example of what what the culture war is
i make an observation based on a legal
theory
we'll see what happens i'm proven right
the young turks double down ignore the
facts and just keep lying well you know
it raises the philosophical question if
you've been insulted by the young turks
have you in fact been insulted
but but you know this is actually the
young turks is just the small version of
this this is happening everywhere the
other day and applebaum of the
washington post
once a fine journalist she was used to
be an actually good writer and
journalist she was approached by a
freshman from the university of chicago
who said to her well how do you feel now
about the fact that the joe biden laptop
has turned out to be true after it was
kicked off twitter it was suppressed by
the news and she said oh that's a boring
story i don't care about that so i
thought well here's a story it really
does implicate the president of the
united states in influence peddling and
she's bored she's bored by that they
shared they shared bank accounts yeah
we've got more data from the laptop
reportedly coming out soon when she says
it was a boring story she's lying but i
know she doesn't know what he's talking
about bingo what boring requires glucose
to change your mind cognitive dissonance
requires a lot of energy to override
i don't know if you know this but even
though we know now that the information
on the laptop is is true and legitimate
it wasn't true back then
okay well that explains it so i'm sorry
i'm sorry you were misinformed about
this but it wasn't true at the time
think about the historical record right
so if you pull up stories
from
you know october 2020 you will learn
about russian disinformation
manipulating the united states
this the story today now is that the
laptop is true
there were opinion pieces commentary
analysis subsequent investigations and
this is the track record we get from the
these establishment crony shill
press be it young turks or otherwise the
russiagate stories they want awards for
those things all based off lives
and now we know what's going on yeah
walter anthony durant you want to pull
through for covering up the hull
tomorrow so here's here's here's the
here's what i want you to imagine this
you look at a history book and they have
a timeline of the donald trump years and
it says in 2016 donald trump colluded
with russia to do this in 2017 donald
trump was investigated for colluding
with russia and then
under the premise that all of those
stories are true which make up the text
of this history book you then get to the
year 2019 2020 and it's like well we now
know that all of the stuff was fake
so how do we go and rewrite the
historical record that they fabricated
you know what i mean well you know but
but just just think about the the
old-fashioned idea of a reporter think
about the guy with the hat the snapping
hat and the press card and his i i was a
reporter i was a small town newspaper
man and you would hang around places
just to see if anything suspicious was
happening so if the councilman walked
into the sheriff's office you
immediately thought what's going on
there what is happening here so here
they have a laptop that connects the
president to his dishonest you know
influenced pedaling son that's like i'm
bored i you know what else is on tv is
that you know is netflix on because i
you know i don't want to
i'd like to imagine there was a time
where the laptop story would come out
and every major news organization would
be like guys guys guys get on this we've
got evidence of direct corruption
involving a president
instead they were like
oh no how do we lie to protect him yeah
well in a weird way hunter's off limits
so people were absolutely vicious
towards trump's children and what they
often said is trump's children are only
successful because they had a rich dad
well look at hunter biden he had a rich
dad and he's very unsuccessful and i'm
not saying the man never dealt with
struggle or hardship but why is it that
trump's kids get their heat fell to the
hell to the fire on everything and
biden's kid is a crackhead and you're
not even allowed to discuss it
you look at you look at don jr and he's
like a a prominent personality and
well-adjusted figure and successful
businessman and then he's the bad one
he's the problem hunter biden had to get
his wood yeah like his teeth replaced
teeth because of his crack addiction
look parmesan cheese addiction yeah no
he was actually remember he was scooping
up parmesan cheese from the carpet yeah
he said that so i feel bad for the guy
over here oh yeah he's had a terrible
like yeah yeah
but my point is more so how the media
treats them
they're like don junior needs to go to
prison and i'm like don junior didn't do
anything i'm just hunter biden did
things we can see and they're like oh
shut up i know i'm going to do the most
boring thing in the world and point out
a double standard here between the left
and the right but just imagine trump's
kid with a crack pipe in their mouth
yeah
that would be it that would be it i
think don junior he tweeted if i did
half the things that hunter biden did
i'd be in prison yeah yeah well no
questions
his dad told him that and now not only
would he be in prison but donald would
be imprisoned that's the thing
the connection on this laptop is getting
worse and worse the stuff you know china
has a very clever strategy that i think
they call what do they call it hunting
the elites or or elite capture elite
capture that's what they call it they
obviously elite capture joe biden
through his son and i you know is that
illegal probably not but but still i
disagree i think they elite captured joe
biden through joe biden and his son was
the intermediary well there you go which
is why
joe biden used air force ii to fly his
son to china for a private equity deal
hold on tech i mean when he was talking
about the big guy he could have been
referring to someone else there could be
some other santa claus
the big guy could be trump that's true
we don't know have we exhausted all of
our resources
yet trump is a big guy exactly trump's
bigger than that
yeah that proves it oh my gosh it's
great it's true you know it's it's funny
how uh
we have the the grooming story now okay
groomer
and it's just fascinating it's almost
like the establishment press left is
it's there there it's
cause and effect is so obvious and
predictable
you know exactly what they're going to
say how they're going to say it when
they're going to say it you could write
their articles for them before they
write it
and then publish them to prove a point
but you'd be talking to nobody you know
like i was mentioning with with you know
ann on the young turks even though an
article comes out
actually proving my point was correct
they act like it never happened just to
clarify you were saying that some of the
people that went to the january 6 event
were just let in and should be not
necessarily charges trespass but then
they interpreted that as you were
talking about the people that were
breaking windows and stuff as well they
were lying okay so that means and
they're doubling down on that
misinterpretation misinterpretation
willful misinformation because
well i i think it's fair to say perhaps
that they're making it up because if
they actually watched anything i said
they would have known that i've always
said that the january 6 writers should
go to prison even in the daily beast
smear piece against me they quoted me
saying that january 6 writers should be
in prison so for the young turks to
protect like i've never like i'm saying
the opposite is ridiculous but this is
this is the point when it comes like the
grooming story when it comes to a
hundred button laptop we talk about
double standards all the time this is
one of the reasons why i think it's kind
of pointless to give them quotes or even
interact with them because you know
exactly what they're gonna do they'll
come out they'll say you are all
fascists then you'll come out and be
like some of these people are groomers
and like
they're making up fake definitions of
words now to lie and smear us and it's
like but it's not even a fake definition
that define i mean if you say you should
be able to have private conversations
with someone else's kid about sexuality
and tell them don't tell your parents
you're grooming them
and even worse even worse on a national
review they're saying well we shouldn't
say gru it's not technically grooming
you think like there's calling a bill
don't say gay that has nothing to do
with not saying gay can we not at least
fight tough can we not at least play the
game the way the game is played i don't
want to i don't want to go dirty but if
they're going to use phrases that are
catchy and actually turn people against
things why can't we this is exactly you
know what i don't think we should call
them the national review because i
cannot believe that that article was
reviewed before they published it that's
insane or that anybody in the nation is
still listening the funny the funny
thing i'm seeing now from a lot of
people on the left on facebook is
they're arguing the bill in florida
someone posted a meme where it's like in
response to this bill i'm gonna stop
talking to kids about traditional
marriage and heterosexuality and i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna use gendered
pronouns and i'm like you are now
arguing that the actual position of the
conservatives is the position they don't
have
you're i'm confused like you are the
ones who created the narrative that it
banned people talking about gay people
when the conservatives never said that
it was just identity in general
and now
you're rev it's it's like they're mad at
themselves there is no arguing
themselves to talk to somebody else's
child in kindergarten about their
sexuality there's no excuse when i was a
kid a cop used to come and visit you in
in school and say if anybody does this
call the police you know the policeman
is your friend he will come and take
this bad guy away now they're actually
saying that there are people on tv
saying you know i'm gay and now i can't
talk to children about my personal life
you know how about that's true teach
them math how about that but also like
am i supposed to cry for that person
like oh no i know but it's not even true
you can still talk about your personal
life if they need to talk about personal
life they need a therapist
to these children right yeah
well so uh i do want to jump to another
story but i'm just curious because
when it comes to the media and the very
obvious predictable nature of the lies
and manipulations i'm curious your
thoughts andrew my attitude's very much
been just ignored at this point because
the moral universes are so disparate
like there's not a single sane rational
human being of of cognitive faculties
who is going to agree that adults should
have sexual conversations with children
in secret but there's the entirety of
the democratic establishment lying to
maintain that right
what do you think the solution is here
that you know what do we do today i
think yeah i think you do have to speak
up for the simple reason that people get
afraid they they think that more people
agree with them than do and so you know
i worked in hollywood for a long time
and i would walk into a meeting and
somebody would come over to me and say i
saw you on on hannity last night at
whisper i saw you on hannity last night
and i was like why are you whispering
we're in the right you know most people
in the country agree with us and the
thing is they can create an atmosphere
of agreement and of being in the
majority that simply isn't the case i
mean look at the fact look at the fact
what happened with disney was this guy
bob chapic he's a conservative he wanted
to take disney out of the politics
a minority of his employees who are
lgbtq
came and yelled at him and he caved
where was the minor where was the
majority sounds like conservatives are
uh have a tendency towards cowardice
yeah yep yep no i was about to say he
sounds like a conservative i think
humans i think humans tend towards
yeah yeah humans seem to be they tend
towards cowardice when they're alone
when they think that's right that's
right yeah big part of this is like you
said speaking up so people know they're
not alone yep i mean you look at what
happened to papa john i'm not surprised
these ceos are like i'll do it i'll do
whatever you say yep absolutely and
that's the other thing they're not going
to get sued by
you know angry conservatives papa john
did nothing wrong
they love this statement that's correct
uh they'll they'll lie and they'll
they'll cheat they'll steal no
manipulate but papa john was on a phone
call and he complained about racism
right he used the word to come he was a
racial slur to complain about the slur
and how someone else had used it no one
cared and we're in a situation now
they've destroyed his life his career
youtube censorship laws is like if you
reference a book from the past that has
a word in it that's now considered
racist you're essentially the the
algorithm treats it as if you're the
ones making the racist comment and
that's dangerous for rhetoric for
society for free speech uh i don't you
know same thing happened to john yeah
and here's another thing conservatives
do they sit and defend youtube and
facebook
saying well they're they're independent
companies so they can do whatever they
want you don't want the government's uh
you know making rules about them well
yeah i do no actually i do the
government is there it was instituted
among men to protect our god-given
rights the first amendment protects
those rights from the government but the
government actually its job is to
protect our free speech rights when you
have things like google which is
controlling 90 of the information flow
amazon which is selling 90 of the new
books
they can be regulated they can be
essentially regulated to make sure that
everybody gets to speak let's let's you
want to judy i just want to add this
it's kind of hilarious we see this a lot
with conservatives basically just
accepting the left-wing framing so what
lefties will say is you believe in free
market capitalism doesn't that mean you
think any big business should be able to
do whatever they want to at any time and
conservatives go i guess you're i guess
i do believe that sir and then they go
off and they fail to achieve anything
whenever they elect their leaders uh but
you look at the left and they've been
sitting there for years going oh no you
know it's a private business they can do
whatever they want and then as soon as
elon musk buys a significant share of
twitter my goodness we can't these
people are too powerful we can't allow
them to influence the public discourse
with their money thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 p.m and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you